Dans les entrailles de l'Afrique
du Sud, quelque chose s'est réveillé.
A l'abri de la lumière, un mystérieux fossile attendait d'être mis au jour depuis
3,7 millions d'années. Une scène de crime qui pourrait
changer à jamais l'histoire de l'évolution humaine.
Au cœur de l'affaire, une victime hors du
commun. Son nom : Little Foot. Sexe : féminin.
Taille : 1 m 30. Son espèce : Australopithecus
prometheus. Particularité : un squelette presque
complet pour identifier les circonstances desa mort, trouver sa place dans le grand arbre
de notre évolution. Un paléo-anthropologue et
un géomorphologiste poursuivent une enquête au
cœur du berceau de l'humanité. En analysantles os de Little Foot, les scientifiques ont
pu décrire la morphologie d'un australopithèqueavec une précision jamais atteinte, et découvert
des indices sur le fonctionnement de soncerveau. Un cerveau bien différent du nôtre,
et qu'un scanner microtomographique a permisde modéliser. Quelles étaient les particularités
d'Australopithecus prometheus ? Comment percevait-t-il son environnement, et combien d'autres
squelettes attendent d'être découverts
dans ces grottes devenues de véritables
pièges à fossiles ? Préparez-vous pour
une enquête au cœur de nos origines.